I can't believe it's been 20 years still
gonna take her father into the
anniversary we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for him
on this day in 1996 the world escaped
the clutches of extinction
your father was the bravest man I've
ever seen
we all lost someone we love but in their
sacrifice we found the technology to
build a stronger and safer earth
because our survival is only possible
when we stand together
oh my god a distress call quietly
screaming they're not screaming they're
celebrating
they're coming back it has its own
gravity
what goes up must come down
shouldn't we be nervous um yeah
our whole lives built up to this moment
it's touchdown over the Atlantic which
pie all of it
make them pay not going out there to
make friends we've gotten remind them
earth is not for the taking
years to get us ready we're going down
we never had a chance we didn't last
time either we convinced an entire
generation
this is a battle that we could win
we sacrifice for each other no matter
what the cost
that's worth fighting for support the
July let's show them some fireworks
they like to get the landmarks
you